[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى حصاد الليله ومعكم ليلى
الشيخي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الخرطوم
حيث تتواصل المعارك في مدن الخرطوم الثلاث
في مختلف انواع الاسلحه تزامنا مع مواصله
البرهان جولاته خارج العاصمه
والى طرابلس والمشهد في ظل قرار ايقاف
وزيره الخارجيه الليبيه نجلاء المنقوش على
خلفيه لقائها نظيرها الاسرائيلي في روما
والى واشنطن
واعلان قاضيه فيدراليه تحديد الرابع من
مارس العام المقبل موعدا لمحاكمه تاريخيه
السابق يعتبر الاجراء تدخلًا انتخابيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
غداه انتهاء المهله الممنوحه للسفير
الفرنسي لمغادره النيجر
يتمسك ببقائه رغم الضغوط ويواجه انتقادات
لحلفاء باريس في التعاطي مع انقلاب النيجر
الاتحاد الاوروبي يؤكد دعمه الكامل لباريس
وقاده الانقلاب يبكون على حاله التاهل
رسائل البرهان من بورسودان الخروج من
الخرطوم بترتيب من الجيش السوداني وليس
عبر صفقه وارفض لاي اتفاق مع الدعم ونائب
رئيس مجلس السياده يقول من بورسودان ان
عده دول اكدت حسمها بالتعامل مع الحكومه
فقط
بعد ايقاف وزيره الخارجيه الليبيه عن
العمل على خلفيه لقائها نظيرها الاسرائيلي
الدببه يلتقي السفير الفلسطيني ويؤكد رفض
بلاده التطبيع واشنطن توجه لوما حادا
للخارجيه الاسرائيليه وتقول ان كشفها عن
اللقاء اضر بمصالح الولايات المتحده
على خط المواجهه في منطقه
موسكو تؤكد صد هجمات على موقع روبوتين
الاستراتيجي جنوبا وكيف تتحدث عن السيطره
عليها وتقر بصلابه خطوط الدفاع الروسيه
البريه
يحذر من فقدان الدعم الغربي اذا نقل
المعركه للداخل الروسي
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا كلمه الرئيس الفرنسي
انتقد فيها مواقف عواصم غربيه من ازمه
النيجر مشيرا الى انه لو لم تتدخل فرنسا
عسكريا في افريقيا لما كانت النيجر
ماليو موجوده اليوم بحدودها المعروفه بحسب
تعبئه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما دلالات هذا
التوصيف للرئيس الفرنسي بشان ابعاد ازمه
النيجر والوضع بافريقيا جاءت للردود على
الشكل التالي
49% اعتبروا ما قاله مكرون تهديدا لدول
افريقيه تفكر في الخروج من نفوذ باريس
مقاله واحد وخمسون في المئه انما قله يعبر
عن غضب من مواقف عواصم غربيه حيال ازمه
النيجر
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بغداد وطهران تؤكدان التوصل لاتفاق امني
بشان الجماعات المسلحه في شمال العراق
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان
السفيره الفرنسيه لدى النيجر سيظل فينيامي
رغم ضغوط قاده الانقلاب واضاف ماكرون في
كلمه امام اجتماع لسفراء في الخارج انه
سمع من واشنطن وعواصم اوروبيه اصواتا تدعو
لعدم المبالغه في التعامل مع الوضع في
النيجر حسب قوله
لدينا رجل منتخب ديمقراطيا وشجاع لانه لم
يتنازل معرضا حياته وعائلته للخطر يقولون
ان السياسه الافضل هي تركهم وشانهم سمعت
اصواتا وقرات صحفا من واشنطن مرورا بعواصم
اوروبيه عده تقول انه لا يتعين علينا
الالتزام بالعياد لان الوضع اصبح خطيرا
يجب علينا ان نكون واضحين وثابتين والا من
سيسمعنا في اي دوله افريقيه يمكننا القول
ان لدينا سياسه شراكه مع مسؤول اذا تعرض
لمثل هذا الوضع ثم لا ندعمه
كما اكد الاتحاد الاوروبي دعمه الكامل
لسفير فرنسا في النيجر واعتبر ان قرار
طرده هو استفزاز جديد
على اوروبا تابعوا تفاصيلها في التقرير
التالي
نفوذ فرنسا يتجه لمزيد من الانحصار في
افريقيا وباريس تدرك ذلك جيدا فالتطورات
في النيجر لم تدع مجالا لاي قراءه سوى ان
فرنسا خسرت ميامه هناك التوجه الرسمي بعد
الاطاحه بالرئيس بازوم يتناغم وقد يقول
كثيرون انه ربما يحرك الهوى الشعبي في
اعتبار فرنسا دوله غير مرغوب فيها يحسن
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون جيدا
قراءه الدلالات دون ان يفوت فرصه تفكير
حلفاء الامس بدور الجيش الفرنسي في حمايه
جغرافيا بعض دول افريقيا حسبما يرى
الاستعلاء بوجه افريقيا في خطاب ماكرون
تقابله رسائل نوم لحلفاء فرنسا الغربيين
لا سيما الاوروبيين مع وجود مخاطر اضعاف
اوروبا والغرب في السياق الدولي الحالي
بحسب مكرم فالتطورات في النيجر اظهرت
مجموعه من التحذيرات التي قد تواجهها
اوروبا
انقطاع اليورانيوم الذي تنتجه النيجر عن
فرنسا قد يؤدي الى تنافس على شرائه ما
يعني ارتفاعا في اسعاره على المدى المتوسط
والتطورات ايضا تفاقم من ازمه الطاقه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يستورد الاتحاد نصف
طاقته النوويه من فرنسا وعليه البحث عن
بدائل كما ان الاتحاد بدل الغاز الروسيه
بامدادات غاز من افريقيا لاسيما عبر انبوب
الغاز العابر للصحراء والذي يتوقع ان ينقل
ثلاثين مليار متر مكعب س نويا من غاز
نيجيريا الى الجزائر ومنها الى اوروبا
ويمر بالنيجر
وتهدد التطورات ان ارتقت لمرحله نزاع
عسكري امدادات النفط في النيجر نفسها عبر
خط يمر في بنين من شانه رفع انتاج نيامي
من النفط واي نزاع مسلح من شانه اي ينعكس
على حقول النفط في نيجيريا وغانا والكوت
ديفوار وسيدفع الارتفاع في اسعار النفط
وزياده معدلات التضخم اما النتائج
المباشره لتطورات النيجر التي بدات تتبلور
فابرزها حاله الارتباك في رحلات الطيران
مع اقفال المجال الجوي النيجري ما ادى
لارتفاع اسعار تذاكر السفر وزياده مبالغ
التامين على الرحلات وتنال فرنسا نصيبا
وافرا من اللوم لمقاربتها ازمه النيجر مع
دعوات لباريس بان تكون اكثر واقعيه وان
تتحمل مسؤوليه الاخفاقات الاقتصاديه
والامنيه
بحسب خبراء
ومعنا الان من واكشوط اسماعيل ولد الشيخ
سيديا الكاتب والمحلل المتخصص في الشان
الافريقي اهلا بك في الحساد اذا فرنسا ومن
خلفها الاتحاد الاوروبي تعتبر طرد السفير
الفرنسي استفزاز وقاده الانقلاب يعتبرون
بقاءه استفزاز كيف يبدو المخرج من حلقه
الاستفزاز هذه وتاثيرها على الازمه في
النيجر
انا اعتقد ان وراء
الاستفزازين كما ذكرت سيدتي الكريمه
ما وراءه لان العسكريين يشعرون ان فرنسا
وقوه المظليين التي ترابط في مطار نياميه
والتي تزيد على لواء
هي شريكه
في كل الاحوال لقوات
الاكواس المحتمله وان الانسان الخاطف الذي
قد يكون سببا في تخليص محمد الرئيس محمد
بازوم ولربما هزيمه العسكريين واظهار عدم
التلاحم
الحرس الجمهوري والقوات الخاصه والحرس
الرئاسي هذه اللحظه يعني بلغت بلاغات ما
بلغتها لدى العسكريين في النيجر معلومات
اكيده بشانها بشان هذا التنسيق العسكري
المحتمل لذلك
يريدون بكل
الاثمان ان يخرج المظليون الفرنسيون الى
تشاد باقل خسائر
والسفير هو وقطع الكهرباء عن السفير
ومضايقه السفير كل هذه هي عناوين لان
فرنسا منذ البدايه محرجه ايضا لانها لان
ما لم تقله فرنسا انها تريد ان تدخل
من الباب الواسع مع الاكواس في مساعده
صديقها المنتخب الديمقراطيا والذي ربما
يستظهر الفرنسيون لاحقا باستغاثه مكتوبه
من رئيس الوزراء
احتجت وما الى ذلك ولكن الاكواس ما زال
يقول ان الخيار العسكري ما زال على
الطاوله هل فعلا هناك خوف حقيقي من جانب
قاده الانقلاب لان يتم فعلا استخدام هذه
الورقه ام هي تهديد اكثر من اي شيء اخر
طبعا المخاوف قائمه والحشد العسكري للنيجر
موجوده على الحدود بنيه وعلى جزء من
الالفا 500
كيلومتر التي تربطهم بنيجيريا وهم يشعرون
اكثر من غيرهم بذلك الحشد لان النسيج
الاجتماعي الموجود على ضفتي الحدود بينهم
وبين نيجيريا هو واحد ومتماسك ولديه او
حتى الاخبار تصل العسكر عبر وسائل الاعلام
خصوصا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الحشود هي هي الان مكشوفه والمشاركه
مكشوفه هنالك سته دول من الاكواس يعني
تطوعت
وشاركت لكن لحظه لحظه صفر لن يكون لان لن
تكون مبرمجه ولن تكون منسقه مع العسكريين
النيجيريين بطبيعه الحال لان لان الحرب
كلها هي خدعه لكن بطبيعه الحال هو ما دام
يتمسكون بالرئيس بازون فلذلك ينقص حظوظ
العمليه العسكريه من الوقوع رغم ذلك رغم
ذلك فالقوات الفرنسيه وهذا هو المسكوت عنه
في هذا التنابز بين العسكريين النيجيريين
والفرنسيين القوه الفرنسيه هي الاكثر قدره
على تلك العمليه الانيقه السريعه لتخليص
بازون اشكرك من نواكشوط اسماعيل وولد
الشيخ سيدي الكاتب والمحلل المتخصص في
الشان الافريقي وارحب من واشنطن
بيسا ويليامز السفيره الامريكيه السابقه
لدى النيجر ونائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي السابق للشؤون الافريقيه
سيده بيسه اريد ان اتوقف عند مقاله ماكرون
اليوم انه سمع من واشنطن وعواصف اوروبيه
اصوات تدعو لعدم المبالغه في التعامل مع
الوضع بالنيجر
كيف تقيمين الطريقه التي يتم التعامل فيها
اوروبيا مبالغه ومن اي نوع
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الدعوه الكريمه اعتقد
ان الوضع في النيجر يصبح اكثر خطوره
واعتقد ان تصريح الذي ادلى به الرئيس
ماكرون بالنسبه الى الطلب بعدم المبالغه
هناك وبكل تاكيد فروقا في الطريقه التي
يتحدث عنها الفرنسيون
بالنسبه الى النيجر وبالمقارنه مع يقال في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول الاخرى
اذا كل الدول طلبت العوده الى النظام
الدستوري الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تطلب
ذلك ايضا الرئيس ماكرون ايضا كان يعبر عن
الاحباط بسبب الدعوه الى طرد السفير
الفرنسي وان الدول في المنطقه لا تتفاعل
ربما بعض الحلفاء حتى من خارج
المنطقه لم يتفاعلون بالطريقه المرجوه
بالنسبه الى النيجر
للطريقه التي تعاملت فيها واشنطن هل فعلا
تعاملت بما يكفي من الدعم لفرنسا هل كان
يمكنها ان تقدم المزيد ولم تفهم
اعتقد ان واشنطن تحاول ان تدعم شعب النيجر
واعتقد انه على الارجح الحكومه الفرنسيه
ولربما الرئيس الفرنسي يرى ان فرنسا لم
تحظى بما يكفي من الدعم ولكن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
ركزت في سياساتها على النيجر على هذا
البلد ولذلك كان الموقف الفرنسي الامريكي
بما رايناه منذ البدايه
الاطراف كثيره ممكن تقول انها تركز على
النيجر ومصلحه الشعب النيجري
هل هناك ما يميز مصالح فرنسا تحديدا هنا
بحيث ربما يبرر هذا الموقف التي تعتبره
واشنطن مبالغا فيه
بحسب تصريح الرئيس مكرون
لا اعتقد ذلك
انا شخصيا ارى ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالنسبه الى هذه الكلمه
المبالغه التي استخدمت اعتقد ان الحديث هو
عن ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تعبر
بنفس النبره وبنفس الكلمات وبنفس الخطابات
ومدى الالحيه التي عبرت من خلالها فرنسا
ولكن خلف الكواليس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ارسلت مبعوثه الى المنطقه
وتحاول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تصبر افضل الطرق للمضيه قدما طبعا لا
اعتقد ان ذلك يتضمن التدخل العسكري ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدعم الايكواس
انا لا ارى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تخطو باتجاه مختلف اذا هذا تفسيري بالنسبه
الى استخدام مصطلح المبالغه هناك ايضا
المصالح المرتبطه
تواجد الفرنسي في المنطقه ولكن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لربما رات ان الطريقه
التي يجب ان تستعرض فيها هذه المرحله
مختلفه عن موقف الرئيس مكرم
السفيره الامريكيه السابقه لدى النيجر
ونائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق للشؤون الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
اكد الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس
مجلس السياده وقائد الجيش في السودان انه
لما كان لحوار مع من سماهم متمردين وخونه
ونفى البرهان مع راجم من تكهنات بشان
خروجه من مقر قياده الجيش في الخرطوم
بقوله ان الحديث عن صفقه في هذا الامر لا
يقول به الا واثم ومن جانب اخر قال الفريق
محمد حمدان دقلو قائد قوات الدعم السريع
في سياق الحديث عن رؤيته لاي تسويه قادمه
الى نظام الحكم الانسب للسودان يجب ان
يكون فيدراليا نتابع تقرير فوزي بشرى
هل خرج الفريق البرهان بالاتفاق مع اعدائه
في الدعم السريع ساعه تقف فيها البنادق
ريثما يبلغ مامنه هل خرج بالترتيبات
اقليميه ترفع عنه اكراهات المكان وانحصاره
فيه كانت الاقاويل تتكاثر والتحليلات تبعد
في النجعه حتى قرر البرهان قتلها جميعا
انا مؤكد انه انا مركت من القياده العامه
دي ما في مساعده
ولا مركت في صفقه ولا مركت باي اتفاق
مركبه الجيش ده عمل عسكري مرتب القوات
المسلحه الجيش
قول والله في اتفاق والله في جهه ساعدت
والله في صفقه
[موسيقى]
قال الفريق البرحان ان عمليه خروجه التي
شاركت فيها الاسلحه من بريه وبحريه وجويه
لم تكن سهله بل سقط اثناءها قتلان وجرحى
وان هذه التضحيات التي قدمها الجيش والشعب
هي ثمن تخليص البلاد من محنتها كل الشعب
السوداني واقف مع الجيش وكله وحداتنا
عشان تهزم هذا التمرد عشان تهزم هذه
الخيانه عشان تهزم هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
واذا كان نفس الصفقه عن الخروج قد سد باب
التكهنات في شانها فان ثمه خشيه من ضغط قد
يقع على البرهان للدخول في مساومه ما فما
اكثر المنابر التي سعت للتعاطي مع الحرب
في السودان سواء في مدينه جده السعوديه
حيث انطلقت اولى محاولات وقفها او في اديس
ابا حيث محاولات التدخل الخشنه التي عبرت
عنها مداولات اجتماعات منظمه الايجاد
والاتحاد الافريقي
والكيانات كلاهما كانا مما فزعت اليه قوه
سودانيه سياسيه مدنيه تستقوي بهما لوقف
حرب كانت هذه القوه نفسها شهودا عليها اذ
تتخلق
وكانت هذه القوه المدنيه هي عينها التي
اقترب منها الفريق حميتي واقتربت منه قبيل
الحرب
يمنيها وتمنيه
[موسيقى]
التحدي الذي يواجهه البرهان هو ان لا يسقط
في منتصف الطريق بنصف انتصار ونصف هزيمه
نزولا على ترتيبات تنهي الحرب وتعيد
التموضع الدعم السريع في الجيش وفي
السياسه فاعلا ببندقيته او بدونها وكان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع الفريق قد ذكر في
اخر تصريحاته ان نظام الحكم في السودان
يجب ان يكون فيدراليا ديمقراطيا
وبسط فكرته بقوله ان النظام الفيدرالي غير
التماثلي هو الانسب لحكم البلاد وهو قول
من ضمن رؤيه كامله للحكم نشرها الدعم
السريع غير ان سيره الدعم السريع في عيون
خصومه ما كانت تعبر عن اي رؤيه سياسيه
فقائد الدعم السريع واخوه كان قليلين
العنايه بالسياسه كثيرين الاهتمام بمراكمه
القوه حتى انتهى حميد الى بناء جيش
جدا للجيش السوداني وجاءت الحرب لتكشف عن
ذلك وتؤكده وما بدا رؤيه سياسيه للحكم هي
في تقدير مناهضيه افكار يتوسل بها حميتي
لاعطاء حربه مضمونا سياسيا فاصحاب الافكار
المبثوثه في رؤيته موجودون يتحركون تحت
ظله
وكشفت الحرب عن خسران كبير الحميطي وقواته
فقضيه انه يقاتل من اجل الديمقراطيه
والمدنيه واستعادتهما هزمتها قوات حميدتي
بما كشفته تقارير وصفتها الولايات المتحده
بالموثوق وتقول ان تلك القوات قتلت وسلبت
ممتلكات ودورا وسيارات وانتهكت اعراضه كما
تواترت الادانات من الامم المتحده
والمنظمات الحقوقيه فالملايين من
السودانيين قد انتهوا نازحين داخل البلاد
او لاجئين الى دول الجوار
لذلك نصف لفكره المدنيه والمدينه لم يقع
في تاريخ السودان الحديث
فالمدينه المدمره هي التجسيد المادي لفكره
المدنيه في السياسه ولهذا فان انتصار
الجيش فيما يقول السودانيون شرط لبقاء
الدوله السودانيه نفسها لان هزيمته ستعني
امرا واحدا وهو انحلال كيان الدوله ولهذا
هي بالنسبه الى السودانيين حرب وجود
ولانها كذلك فهي حرب ضروره هل يملك
البرهان وقد خرج من محبسه القدره فضلا عن
الجراه للسير ضد المزاج الرافض لنصف
انتصار ونصف هزيمه
ومعنى الان هنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين
بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
اهلا وسهلا بك
اذا قبل خطاب البرهان اذ كان هناك امل لدى
كثيرين بان هناك محاولات جاريه فعلا
للتوصل لحل تفاوضى بين الطرفين
هل الخطاب الان اغلق هذه الصفحه دخلنا في
مرحله جديده ام ماذا نعم هو امتداد الخطاب
السابق بان هنالك محاوله انقلابيه من قبل
الدعم السريع وان الجيش يزعل لتفكيك هذه
المحاوله اذا كان ذلك عبر العمليات
العسكريه المتواصله او عبر العمل التفاوض
والعمل التفاوضي تم الاتفاق عليه في اتفاق
في مبادره جده السعوديه الامريكيه ولكن لم
يتم الالتزام من قبل الدعم السريع بهذه
المبادئ التي تم اقرارها في ذلك الوقت حيث
الزمن ذلك الاتفاق الدعم السريع بالخروج
من الاعيان المدنيه ومن المنازل ومن غير
ذلك ولكن الدعم السريع لم يلتزم بل ظل
يراوغ ويضطرب في تقديم روايات تفسيريه
للتجاوزات التي تمت في تلك
الطرفين في الواقع هي الطربان الطرفين
وانا طرفي مسؤولان عما وصلت اليه الامور
والكل يسال عن المخرج وهل هم هناك فعلا
امكانيه بعد ايضا الرؤيه التي طرحها حمتي
اسمحي لي ان اقول لك بان هذه المساواه
مساواه غير عادله كانت هنالك محاوله
انقلابيه من قبل الدعم السريع وكانت هنالك
تجاوزات وهذه التجاوزات ليست تهم تلقى من
قبل الطرف الاخر او من قبل من يوالون
الطرف الاخر ولكن المنظمات الامميه
والوكالات الانباء العالميه وكثير جدا حتى
من خبراء في الامم المتحده تحدثوا عن
التجاوزات الفظيعه التي يرتكبها الدعم
السريع والمتعلقه
بالاحتلال المنازل والاعيان المدنيه
والاغتصاب
وما يسمى بالاغتصاب
الجماعي والذي مورس وتم اثباته حتى في
التقرير الخاص بمنظمه العفو الدوليه
فبالتالي هذه هي الحقائق ولكن حين ما ننظر
الى الانتهاكات التي يشار اليها يشار بان
القشره ارتكبها هنالك بعض الاتهامات بانه
ما رزق قصف لبعض المناطق في في مدنيين
وكذلك هنالك اتهام اكبر لو سمحت اكبر بان
الجيش تراخه ولم يقم بدوره الاساسي في
حمايه المدنيين في الجنينه حينما تعرضوا
لتلك الجرائم ولم تعرضوا للاغتصاب وتعرضوا
للحق اليه الاطراف انه في نوع من التخبط
والفوضى من الطرفين بغض النظر عن
حجم الازمه
بالنظر عن كونها عادله ام لا هناك ازمه
وهناك كارثه انسانيه
والسؤال هو عن افق الحل يعني الان تتحدث
ايضا عن مبادره عن مخرج هل يمكن فعلا نعم
قبل الحديث عن الحلاب لابد ان يتم تقسيم
عادي لهذه التجاوزات لان هذا هذه التعبئه
وضم الامر في طرفين اعتقد انه انه في
تشويه للحقائق هذا امر اول المبادرات تمضي
ولكنها تمضي بتعثر لان الدعم السريع لا
يريد ان يلتزم ربما لا يرغب او ربما يفقد
المقدره على
هو ليس مؤهل لتقديم اي اطروحات متعلقه
بالمستقبل هو طالما انه يقوم بتدمير
الحاضر ويشوه الماضي
بالاعتداءات على على المتاحف وغير ذلك
فاعتقد انه الان هو مجرم بسلوكه وليس مؤهل
لان يقدم وصفه
ولو كانت استراريه وصفه كان فيها اقترار
لبعض الادميات المستهلك اصلا ولم ياتي
فيها بجديد ولكنه حتى الى هذا الحد فهو
غير مؤهل لتقديم هذه الوصفه لان ما يرتكبه
من جرائم وما يرتكبه من تجاوزات تخرجه من
المعادله السياسيه ككل وتظهره كمجرم حرب
اذا كان ذلك على مستوى القياده او مستوى
المجموع
المقاتل بالنسبه للدعم السريع اشكرك ضياء
الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني شكرا جزيلا على وجدة
[موسيقى]
موقع اكسيوس الى اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وجهت احتجاجا شديد اللهجه الاسرائيل
عقب الكشف عن اللقاء بين وزير الخارجيه
اليكوهين ووزيره الخارجيه الليبيه نجلاء
المنقوش واضاف الموقع ان مسؤولين امريكيين
كبارا اعتبروا ان الكشف عن الخبر اضر
بالمصالح الامنيه الامريكيه في ليبيا كما
اضر الكشف عن اللقاء بمساعد دفع بتطبيع
العلاقات بين اسرائيل وليبيا ودول عربيه
اخرى وفي سياق متصل قال مراسل اكسيوس نقلا
عن مسؤولين في مكتب وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي ان الاداره الامريكيه طلبت من
الجانب الاسرائيلي التهدئه وشددت على انه
لم يكن هناك اي احتجاج امريكي بهذا الخصوص
ادرم محتجون النار امام مبنى رئاسه مجلس
الوزراء حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس تمديدا بلقاء المنقوش
بوزير الخارجه الاسرائيلي وردد المحتجون
هتافات داعمه للقضيه الفلسطينيه رافضه لاي
تواصل الليبي مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
كما اقتحم متظاهرون في العاصمه طرابلس
سابق وزاره الخارجيه دون احتكاك مع
الاجهزه الامنيه وطلب المتظاهرون باقاله
وزيره الخارجيه ومحاسبتها
رحبت وزاره الخريه الفلسطينيه بزياره رئيس
حكومه الوحده الليبيه عبد الحميد دبيبه
سفاره دوله فلسطين في طرابلس وقالت
الخارجيه في بيان لها اعلن من داخل سفارته
فلسطين رفض بلاده التطبيعه مع اسرائيل
وتجريم اي اتصال يجمع اي مسؤول
بممثل لدوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
طلب مجلس النواب الليبيه النائبه العام
بالتحقيق مع حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه
عبد الحميد دبيبه فيما وصفه بجريمه
التواصل مع الكيان الصهيوني وعاقب جلسه
طارئه في بنغازي شرقيه ليبيا دعا المجلس
الى تشكيل لجنه من مجلسي النواب والاعلى
للدوله للعمل على تشكيل حكومه مصغره
بالتعاون مع البعثه الامميه واوصى بيان
المجلس لجنه 6 + 6 المشتركه بمنع من ثبت
تورطه بالتعامل مع اسرائيل من الترشح
وتضمين ذلك في شروط الانتخاب
[موسيقى]
ولاني الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذا
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقدم قواتها
فيزا واستعاده السيطره على بلده روبوتينو
في المقاطعه وتعتبر هذه البلده مركز
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد في مقاطعه
عليها تعني اختراق خط الدفاع الروسي الاول
في المقاطعه وقالت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انها استعاده السيطره على نحو
كيلومتر مربع جنوبي بخموت في مقاطعه
واضافت ان القوات الاوكرانيه استعادت
السيطره على 44 كيلومترا مربعا من جبهه
بخموت منذ بدايه الهجوم المضاد
ومن جهه نفهه مصادر عسكريه روسيه سيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه على بلده روبوتينو فيزا
وقالت ان معارك تدور حول البلده وان
القوات الاوكرانيه دفعت بالمزيد من
التعزيزات وانها تحاول اختراقها من الجهه
الشماليه لكن دون تحقيق اي تقدم وقد بث
موانونا لروسيا فيزا صورا قالوا انها
لتدمير مدرعتين امريكيتي الصنع من طراز
برادلي تابعه للجيش الاوكراني على مشارف
البلده
ونبقى في الملف الاوكراني اذا اعلنت
السلطات الروسيه احباط هجمات شنتها طائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه في موسكو
والقرن وقال رئيس بلديه موسكو نادي
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت الطائره مسيره كانت
تحلق باتجاه العاصمه الروسيه وقد اغلق
مطران دوليان في موسكو فتره وجيزه امام
المغادرين والوافدين قبل ان تستانف
العمليات لاحقا
نقلت محطه عن الرئيس الاوكراني
ان نقل الحرب الى الاراضي الروسيه محفوف
بالمخاطر وانه في حال تم ذلك سيترك
الاوكرانيون لمصيرهم وستبقى اوكرانيا
وحدها
الخلاف واضح بين واشنطن وكييف على خلفيه
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد تنقل صحيفه وولو
جورنال عن مسؤولين امريكيين واشنطن سبق
وان نصاحه اوكرانيا بتغيير استراتيجيه
الهجوم فبدلا من نشر قواتها على جبهات عده
من الافضل تركيزها هجماتها على مناطق يمكن
فيها تحقيق اي اختراق الهدف من هذه
الاستراتيجيه الوصول الى بحر ازوف تستند
النصيحه الامريكيه بحسب ما تنقل الصحيفه
الى حساب حجم المساعدات العسكريه الكليه
لاوكرانيا والتي فقط ثلاثه واربعين مليار
دولار على مدى سنوات قليله وبحسب مسؤول
امريكي فان حجم ونوعيه هذه المساعدات لن
تتكرر حاولت اوكرانيا الدفاع عن تكتكاتها
الميدانيه وغيرت من نوعيه هجماتها وباتت
تستهدف بشكل مكثف شبه جزيره القرم والعمق
الروسي ثم تصريح مفاجئ من الرئيس
الاوكراني يقول فيه ان نقل للداخل الروسي
محفوف بالمخاطر ليتحدث الرجل ايضا وربما
للمره الاولى منذ اشهر عن حل سياسي ممكن
في القرن مجله يزوي كانت تحدثت عن وجود
خلافات متزايده داخل القياده الاوكرانيه
بسبب الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد المخيب
للامال بحسب الصحيفه وتضيف نيوزويك انه
بات على الرئيس الاوكراني الاختيار بين
بدل كل جهد ممكن وبالتالي المخاطره بفشل
مكلف او خفض خسائر اوكرانيا وقبول هزيمه
مدمره سياسيه لكن اكثر ما تخشاه واشنطن
بحسبريت جورنال ان تكون معركه اوكرانيا ضد
روسيا قد دخلت في طريق المسدود
قال المركز العسكري الروسي في قاعده احميم
ان الطائرات التحالف الدولي في سوريا
انتهت اليوم
بروتوكولات عدم الاشتباك تسع مرات وذلك
باستخدام طائرات مسيره وقد صاعدت في
الاونه الاخيره وتيره الاحتكاك الجوي بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده في اجواء سوريا
ما يطرح تساؤلات عن جدوى اتفاقيه منع
التصادم التي تحكم الانشطه الجويه بين
طرفين في سوريا
الثالث والعشرون من يوليو تموز الماضي في
سماء سوريا تقترب مقاتله روسيه وفق الجيش
الامريكي من طائره امريكيه مسيره من نوع
ام كيو 9 تضايقها وتطلق مشاعر مضيئه من
نقطه تعترض مسار المسير مباشره ومن مسافه
امتار قليله لتصيب احداها مروحه الطائره
المسيره وتلحق بها اضرارا بالغه حادثه من
بين اخريات تكررت دفعت وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لدعوه القياده الروسيه للتاكد من
انها تصدر توجيهات لقواتها لما سماه
الالتزام بقوانين السماء دعوه تعكس حجم
التوتر الذي اضحت الاجواء السوريه مسرحا
له
فثلاثه ايام بعد الحادث قال مركز المصالحه
الروسي في سوريا ان طائره مسيره تابعه
للتحالف الدولي الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده اقتربت بما ينذر بالخطر من طائره
عسكريه روسيه من طراز سوخوي 34 في يوم
واحد وفق المركز سجلت ثمن حالات انتهاك
لبروتوكولات تفادي التصادم لثلاث طائرات
مسيره امريكيه في منطقه التنف وبالمجمل في
حصيله شهر يوليو الماضي لوحده تحدث المركز
عن نحو 300 تجاوز امريكي لبروتوكولات منع
التصادم ونحو 23 مواجهه خطيره هذا العام
من طيران التحالف مع الطائره الروسيه في
سماء سوريا بالمقابل في السادس من يوليو
تموز الفائت افادت القوات الجويه
الامريكيه من خراط طائره روسيه في مسمته
سلوكا غير امن وغير احترافي اثناء
مشاركتها في مهمه ضد تنظيم الدوله في
الاجواء السوريه وتحدث مسؤول امريكيون عن
وجود شركات جويه روسيه امريكيه في الاجواء
السوريه في يوليو الماضي نحو ست مرات خط
عدم الاشتباك بين الجيشين في سوريا لتجنب
الاخطاء بالمواجهات غير المقصوده دفع
البلدين للاعلان في تشرين الاول اكتوبر
عام 2015 عن اتفاقيه لمنع التصادم بين
الطائره الروسيه والامريكيه في الاجواء
السوريه تتضمن قواعد وقيودا يجب على اطقم
الطيران اتباعها بالاضافه الى انشاء حلقه
اتصالات ارضيه بين الجانبين في حال تعطل
الاتصالات الجويه وان تحرص الطائرات في
الجانبين على الحفاظ على مسافه امنه تتهم
روسيا واشنطن بالقيام برحلات جويه غير
قانونيه في سوريا وتفعيل طيارها انظمه
الاسلحه عند الاقتراب من الطائره الروسيه
بينما يتهم المسؤولون الامريكيون الطيارين
الروس باستخدام اساليب غير مهنيه واستفزاز
طائرات التحالف الدولي خلال القيام بعمليه
ضد تنظيم الدوله
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه جينا ريموندو عن اتفاق لافت بين
الصين والولايات المتحده لتاسيس مجموعه
عمل جديده تبحث جوانب التوتر في المسائل
التجاريه بين البلدين تعد هذه الزياره
الثالثه لمسؤول امريكي هذا العام الى
بيجين بعد وزيري الخارجيه والخزانه
بين الصين والولايات المتحده اقتصادان
توصف العلاقه بينهما بالحرب البارده
المعلنه فلماذا جاءت وزيره التجاره
الامريكيه الى بيجين جاءت خلاصه الزياره
في اعلان تاسيس مجموعه عمل هدفها ايجاد
حلول لقضايا التجاره والاستثمار والدفع
قدما بالمصالح التجاريه الامريكيه في
الصين لا احد من الطرفين يريد القطيعه اذا
بل ان ارقام المبادلات التجاريه بين
البلدين تشير الى ان العام الماضي سجل
اعلى مستوى لها على الاطلاق ببلوغه 690
مليار دولار وبتحقيق بضائعها نسبه 20% من
اجمالي واردات السلع الامريكيه ما تزال
الصين ثالث اكبر شريك تجاري للولايات
المتحده بعد كندا والمكسيك
على هذه الواردات القادمه من الصين تفرض
الولايات المتحده قيودا تقول انها ضروريه
لحمايه امنها القومي تصف واشنطن اجراءاتها
هذه بسياسه تحجيم المخاطر في يونيو حزيران
الماضي اضافت اداره بايدن 59 شركه صينيه
الى قائمه كيانات يحذر على الامريكيين
الاستثمار فيها يشمل نشاط تلك الشركات
خاصه صناعه اشباه الموصلات والتكنولوجيا
الناشئه مثل الذكاء الصناعي حتى وهي تقترب
من بيجين تشدد واشنطن على تمسكها بسياسه
تحجيم المخاطر
اود ان اكون واضحه نحن لا نتنازل او
نتفاوض في مسائل الامن القومي ولكن
المقصود من هذا ان يكون حوارا نزيد فيه
الشفافيه ونكون واضحين بشان ما نفعله فيما
يتعلق بانفاذ مراقبه الصادرات
اما بيجين فتعد القيود الامريكيه على
صادراتها ومنع الامريكيين من الاستثمار في
شركاتها مساعيه للحد من نمو الصين
الاقتصادي فبسبب سياسه تحجيم المخاطر التي
تنتهجها واشنطن تراجع حجم الاستثمار
الاجنبي في الصين بنحو النصف خلال العام
الماضي حيث ابتعد كثير من المستثمرين بسبب
القلق من المخاطر الجيوسياسيه بين البلدين
خلافات شديده اذ لدى بيجين مطالبات
اقليميه في بحر جنوب الصين تعارضها واشنطن
وثمت قلق امريكي من علاقات الصين بروسيا
بشان حرب اوكرانيا وهناك قضيه تايوان التي
يوجد فيها الصينيون والامريكيون على طرفي
نقيض واخر فصولها موافقه واشنطن الاسبوع
الماضي على بيع اسلحه بقيمه 500 مليون
دولار لتايوان
[موسيقى]
تطور في ملف الجماعات المسلحه في شمال
العراق بغداد وطهران تكشفان عن اتفاق لنزع
سلاح هذه المجموعات واغلاق مقرها كيف يبدو
المشهد على طول
1460 كيلومترا تمتد الحدود العراقيه
الايرانيه ربع هذه المسافه يشهد توترا من
فتره الى اخرى عنوانه نشاط الاحزاب
الكرديه المعارضه للظهر هذه الاحزاب التي
تتهمها طهران باستغلال الحدود المشتركه
لتهريب اسلحه الى الداخل ايران مستقله او
مستقره بالاحرى في اقليم كردستان العراق
الذي يضم ثلاث محافظات هي سليمانيه اربيل
ودهوك على مدى السنوات التي اعقبت عام
2003 شهدت هذه الحدود المشتركه بين البل
دين انفلاتا ساهم في دخول اسلحه ومتفجرات
وعبوات ناسفه وجماعات مسلحه الى داخل
ايران كما تقول طهران فضلا عن عمليات
تحريك
في منتصف يوليو الماضي اعلنت وزاره
الداخليه العراقيه نشره كتيبه على الحدود
بالتنسيق مع سلطات اقليم كردستان العراق
وقد تم نصف نحو 50 برج مراقبه واربعين
كاميرا هناك وذلك تم ذلك خلال شهرين
اكتوبر ونوفمبر من العام الماضي في هذه
الفتره شنت ايران سلسله هجمات صاروخيه
ومدفعيه وبطائرات مسيره مفخخه استهدفت
مقرات ومناطق وجود الاحزاب والجماعات
الكرديه الايرانيه المعارضه
طبعا تم التطرق الى هذا الملف تكرارا بين
المسؤولين الايرانيين والعراقيين في اطار
تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه وفي الساعات
الاخيره اعلن الجانبه اتفاقا بشان الترتيب
الامني فكيف تبدو التفاصيل
الناطق باسم وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه
ناصر كنعاني قال انه بناء على الاتفاق
المبرم بين حكومتي ايران والعراق فقد
التزمت الحكومه العراقيه بنزع سلاح ما
سماه الجماعات الارهابيه المسلحه في
العراق
واجلائها من السكنات العسكريه
اضاف كنعاني ان التاريخ التاسع عشر من
سبتمبر والذي حدد لنقل هذه المجموعات الى
المعسكرات التي تحددها للحكومه العراقيه
لن يتم تمديده مثلا ينفذ الاتفاق فان
الايرانيين
سيقومون بمسؤوليتهم في اطار الحفاظ على
امن ايران
ماذا عن بغداد هشام الركابي المستشار
الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء العراقي قال ان
الاتفاق الامني مع ايران بشان الجماعات
المسلحه في شمال العراق ينص على ثلاث نقاط
تتعلق هذه النقاط بمنع تسلل المسلحين
وتسليم المطلوبين وفقا للقانون اضافه الى
نزع السلاح وازاله المعسكرات كذلك اضافه
مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي انا الاتفاق
مع طهران هو رساله الى دول الجوار مفادها
ان العراق سيمنع وجود اي جماعات مسلحه
تهدد امن وسلامه تلك الدول
الان نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيفينا من طهران
عباس اصلاني الباحث في مركز الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من بغداد ايضا
الدكتور عدنان السراج رئيس المركز العراقي
للتنميه الاعلاميه اهلا بكما في الحصاد
ابدا معك سيد او دكتور عدنان السراج هذه
الجماعات المسلحه المناهضه لايران كانت
موجوده في المنطقه الحدوديه لسنوات
كيف سيتخلص منها او يخرجها العراق خلال
ثلاثه اسابيع
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيفك العزيز ولمشاهديك الكرام نعم نكاد
نزهم بان وجود الجماعات المعارضه على
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه كان مصدر قلق
واحراج بالنسبه للحكومه العراقيه لكن واقع
الحال يقول تطورت الامور بشكل دراماتيكي
وسريع من خلال يعني نزوح العديد من
اللاجئين الايرانيين الى المعارضين الى
الحدود العراقيه ودخولهم في معسكرات نصبت
قريبه على الحدود الايرانيه العراقيه ولكن
بمرور زمن نتيجه تعقيدات المنطقه يتحولت
هذه المعسكرات الى عمليات تدريب يعني
تجنيد لعناصر للقيام بعمليات ضد ايران
العراق بشكل
هذا الامر بمضاد ما هي الاليات التي توضع
للتاكد من ان هذا الامر يمكن فعلا التحكم
فيه
سيدتي العزيزه الامر العراقي يعني يمكن ان
يسيطر على الحدود سابقا كانت الحدود
ممسوكه لكن العامل الرئيسي الذي كان مصدر
خلاف مع الاقليم هي مساله تواجد قوات
عراقيه اضافه الى الحرس الحدود حرس الحدود
لن يستطيع ان يوفر امكانيات الدفاع عن
الاراضي العراقيه ولا ضبط الحدود العراقيه
ليس فقط من خلال عبور يعني المقاتلين الى
ايران او المعارضين الى ايران او على
العكس من ذلك دخول بعض العناصر العراق
وكذلك عمليات تهريب والمخدرات ذلك العراق
اليوم بدا بارسال العديد حسب مذكره
التفاهم بين مستشار الامن الوطني العراقي
ومستشار الامن الوطني الايراني في توقيع
هذه المذكره قبل اشهر التي يعني دفع
العراق فيها بالتعاون مع اربيل باكثر من
6000 من العناصر الداعمه لحرس الحدود مع
توفير الاسلحه اللازمه
ووضع الابراج والنقاط على
والله
الحقيقه اعتقد ان التعاون بين الحكومه
الايرانيه والحكومه العراقيه الحاليه كان
جيدا جدا بالمقارنه مع الحقبات السابقه
وكما سبق وذكرتم في تقريركم هذه المشكله
كانت متواجده منذ سنوات في تلك المنطقه
اعتقد ان المسؤولين الايرانيين يتحدثون
ويقولون انه اذا لم يتم الالتزام بهذا
الموعد سوف تتخذ ايران التدابير المناسبه
وهنا نعود الى الخطوات والتدابير
الايرانيه السابقه اي القصف الايراني نعم
القصف الايراني
لمعسكرات المجموعات
المعارضه وايران ايضا تحدثت عن علاقه بين
هذه المجموعات واسرائيل في السابق ان
ايران
لا بالعكس العراق بلجان المشتركه يعني حتى
قبل ايام كان هناك وفد امني عراقي هذه
اللجان المشتركه تعمل بشكل ايجابي وهي
تقول بان ما تم من اجراءات فعلا هو تنفيذ
اتفاقيه او التفاهم بين ايران والعراق
وبالتالي انتشار الجنود العراقيين وحرس
الحدود على المراكز المهمه بالتاكيد كان
هناك رضا ايراني من هذا الاجراء العراقي
لكن بالنسبه ذي مساله القبض على
المطلوبين هناك مذكرات قبض تجري في
المحاكم العراقيه وبالتعاون مع الجهات
المختصه القضائيه من اجل يعني تنفيذ البند
الثاني من القاء القبض على هؤلاء وايضا
زجهم الى القضاء من اجل المحاكمتهم
بالاضافه لذلك هناك اجراءات عراقيه لنقل
المعسكرات اذا العمق العراقي في غرب اقليم
كردستان ونزع سلاح القوى الكرديه هذا
العمل يتطلب اجراء عراقيه صارمه اذا سمحت
لي انتقل السيد عباس اصلا اذا واضعنا
الاجراءات العراقيه جانبا والمطالب
الايرانيه ايضا جانبا هل الموضوع عراقي
ايراني بحث ام هناك اطراف اخرى ربما من
مصلحتها ان تبقي هذه الجماعات في هذه
المنطقه كورقه ضغط ربما على طهران او اي
امر اخر له ابعاد سياسيه وكذلك
عندما نتحدث عن المجموعات الكرديه في
المنطقه هناك بعض البلدان التي لديها
اهتمام بهذه المساله وان مساله الاتفاق
بين ايران والعراق
يؤدي الى منع التهديدات باتجاه ايران
وتركيا والعراق يبدو ان بعض البلدان كما
تفضلتي تود ان تحافظ على هذه المجموعات
كدوله كورقه
الذي يتم الحديث عنه الان هذا الاتفاق
المبرم الان ما دور هذه الدول ومن تقصد
اعتقد الان بالنسبه الى الاصرار الايراني
والتعاون مع الحكومه العراقيه
السبب وراء ذلك هو
ذكرى المظاهرات التي حصلت في سبتمبر في
البلاد ولذلك تطلب ايران من الحكومه
العراقيه ان تحترم هذه المهله الزمنيه وان
تتاكد من احراز تقدم بحلول ايلول سبتمبر
بالنسبه الى مجموعات المعارضه هذه ولذلك
نستمع او يسلط الضوء على هذه المساله بشكل
كيف ترى انت الموقف عراقي ايراني بحث ام
ترى اطراف اخرى لها يد في تحديد هذه
المهله والتاريخ وايضا ردود الفعل
راقيه راها قضيه عراقيه يعني تمس الامن
العراقي وايضا تمس علاقاته بدول الجوار
ذلك ويقوم باجراءات دون النظر الى
الادعاءات الايرانيه سواء كان هناك دوله
اخرى او دول اخرى تدفع في هذه الجهه نعم
قد يكاد تكون جهود مخابراتي ايراني يدعو
يعني يدعي ذلك لكن العراق لا يلتزم بهذا
الامور الا بحفظه للحدود العراقيه
الايرانيه وانتشار القوات العراقيه
بالمناسبه العراقيون المسؤولين العراقيين
بالتعاون مع الماسوني الايرانيين يجدون
بان الاجراءات العراقيه اجراءات جيده
وبانه التصريحات الايرانيه الاخيره في
تحديد الفتره الزمنيه والتي لن تتوفر اي
يعني معلومات عن ورود هكذا مده زمنيه في
مذكره التفاهم بين الطرفين العراقيين الا
ان العراق يعتبر هذه التصريحات هي الضغط
على الجهات المعارضه اكثر من الضغط على
الحكومه العراقيه هم يوجهون رسالتين رساله
للحكومه العراقيه بين الاجراءات جيده
ويمكن ان تدفع القوات العراقيه
يعني من ذهب سامحوني عباس اصلاني هل هناك
اليه للمتابعه
تطمئن ايران في هذه المرحله بمعنى اذا
انتهى هذا التاريخ الذي تحسب له ايران الف
حساب في سبتمبر يمكن ان ينفجر الموضوع من
جديد ويخف ربما الضغط
ان ايران سوف تحاول ان تراقب العمليه
وتنضم الى العمليه وتتاكد من ان يحصل هذا
التقدم في عمليه نزع سلاح المجموعات
المعارضه وهذا سوف يكون مؤشرا للايرانيين
بان يثقوا بجهود الحكومه العراقيه ولقد
شاهدنا التدابير الحسنه في هذا المجال
واعتقد ان كلا الطرفين اذا ما اتفقاه على
تضافر وتازر الجهود في هذا المجال من اجل
تحقيق التقدم اعتقد انه باستطاعتهما ان
يتناقش بالخطوات المستقبليه ولكن اذا ما
رات ايران انهما من تقدما في هذه الحاله
الموقف يختلف اشكرك جزيلا من طهران عباس
اصلاني البحث في مركز الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه واشكر الدكتور
عدنان السراج رئيس الم ركز العراقي
للتنميه الاعلاميه من بغداد شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
ونختم بهذه الفكره عن تواصل الصراعات
والحروب والانتهاكات باشكالها المختلفه
والثمن طبعا يدفعه الجميع خصوصا الاطفال
والشبان اي اصحاب المستقبل دفع ذلك لجنه
تابعه للامم المتحده للاعلام للمره الاولى
اليوم ان جميع الاطفال الحق في بيئه نظيفه
وصحيه يعني ذلك بحسب ما اوضحت الامم
المتحده ان الدول ملزمه بمكافحه مشاكل مثل
التلوث وتغير المناخ تاتي مواقف لجنه حقوق
الطفل بعد اسبوعين فقط من حكم قادم في
ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه لصالح شبان
اتهموا ولايتهم بانتهاك حقهم الدستوري في
بيئه نظيفه وصحيه وفي اماكن اخرى من
العالم حكم القضاء بشكل واضح لصالح شبان
في كولومبيا هاجم شبان حكومتهم منددين
بازاله وفي المانيا تمكنا اطفال من تشديد
قانون انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد
واقع الحال انا الحفاظ على البيئه هو
مسؤوليه الجميع الاطفال الشبان الكبار
الكل على السفر دمتم بخير
[موسيقى]